sí
ya que sabemos cómo graficar puntos en
un plano coordenada estamos listos para
empezar a diseñar una toma echémosle un
vistazo a este boceto que tenemos de la
habitación de andy en 'toy story'
podemos ver que vos y bobby están en el
piso o en la cama colocados un poco como
al azar también podemos ver en este
boceto que surge una pregunta en donde
queremos poner la lámpara la queremos
poner junto a la cama como para que la
persona que vive ahí la pueda usar o la
queremos en el tocador porque queremos
decir que el adulto es quien la utiliza
el lugar donde ponemos cualquier cosa
significa algo y los verdaderamente
buenos gráficos por computadora nos
cuentan una historia cada vez que
colocan cada uno de los objetos
para construir una toma el departamento
de modelado nos manda un conjunto de
objetos con los que podemos trabajar en
pixar a esta colección le llamamos una
biblioteca de objetos como en esta
lección vamos a trabajar en dos de
nuestros objetos son imágenes 2d pero
cuando hacemos esto en serio en una
película de pixar nuestros objetos son
modelos tridimensionales tanto en el
caso 2d como en el 3d elegimos un punto
de referencia sobre el objeto para
ayudar a su colocación y podemos escoger
cualquier punto de referencia que
queramos en esta lección vamos a escoger
la esquina inferior izquierda los
objetos que metamos a la toma van a
aparecer con el punto de referencia en
el origen para diseñar mi toma voy a
empezar con el tocador porque es una de
las formas más grandes con las que voy a
tener que trabajar una vez que el objeto
ya está en la toma
puedo colocarlo donde yo quiera
utilizando la operación de traslación
por ejemplo podemos moverlo 5 unidades
hacia la derecha y 5 unidades hacia
arriba para trasladar al objeto completo
tenemos que trasladar cada uno de los
puntos así es que es si elijo este punto
sobre el objeto inicial les podemos
llamar a sus coordenadas x 0 10/0 ese
punto se va a mover a este otro punto
después de la traslación y a esas nuevas
coordenadas les podemos llamar x 1 y 1
por aquí
esta fórmula nos está diciendo que las
matemáticas de la traslación son la suma
y cuando hago clic en un punto en la
posición inicial puedes ver aquí a dónde
se va ese punto y también qué es lo que
sucede con las coordenadas así es que
siempre que veas objetos que han viendo
de lugar en nuestras películas ya sabes
que en el fondo hay una traslación y por
lo tanto también hay una suma tu primera
tarea consiste en seleccionar elementos
de la biblioteca de objetos
a crear un primer borrador de ese dibujo
que te dio el departamento de historias
para mantener las cosas simples en esta
primera tarea solo te vamos a permitir
utilizar la operación de traslación así
es que no vas a poder diseñar toda la
toma tu trabajo consiste en averiguar
qué objetos puedes colocar usando
únicamente la traslación no debes
escoger objetos que requieran rotación
ni modificación de tamaño todavía y si
añades algún objeto por error siempre
puedes hacer clic en eliminar muy buena
suerte